بعد جنازه الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه وظهور
الملك تشارلز مع ابنيه في لقطات عده توقع
كثيرون بان تنتهي فتره البرود والجافه
التي تعيشها العائله الملكيه البريطانيه
لكن تتبدد هذه التوقعات بين الحين والاخر
في بعد وثيقين فليكس تاتي مذكرات الامير
هاري لمضمونا اكبر من المتوقع يزيد من
الشرح بينه وبين عائلته الاكثر ترى فيها
هو ما كتبه على اعتداء شقيقه وليام عليه
حتى ان الصحافه البريطانيه احتارت في
اختيار العناوين صحيفه زيلي ميرور الشعبيه
في عنوانها قالت لاحد بمن انت عن مهمه
هاري الوحشيه لتدمير الاسره اما صحيفه
اتهمت الامير المقيم في كاليفورنيا للقاء
عائلته تحت حافله اتتابع المزيد مع عروض
جديده
[موسيقى]
اراد هاري الخصوصيه لكنه لا يبدو متحفظا
على الكشف عن تفاصيل حياته وحياه عائلته
الملكيه اراد الابتعاد عن الاضواء لكن بعد
مقابلات عده ووثائقيا هوليودي وكتاب
المرتقب لا يبدو ان رغباته او كلماته
تتماشى مع افعاله فماذا يريد الامير
المتمرد
اذا الوقت
مع والده واخيه لكنه يضع الكره في ملعبهم
لتولي مهمه اعاده العلاقه الى سابقها
يريد عوده الامور الى مجارها مع الملك
تشارلز وولي العهد الامير وليام لكنه لا
يتوانى عن كشف تفاصيل مزعجه عن اخيه الذي
تقع على عاتقه مهمه الحفاظ على ارث
العائله لاجيال القادمه
ههه تسريبات جديده يزعم فيها هاري ان
الامير وليام هجمه جسديا في كتاب يتضمن
تفاصيل الخلاف الشهير بين الشقيقين عام
كتاب الامير هاري سبير الذي من المتوقع
نشره في العاشر من هذا الشهر باكثر من 16
لغه مختلفه وكتاب صوته سيكون قاسيا على
وليام على وجه الخصوص اذ يتهممه هاري
بالاساءه الى زوجته بعد نعتها بالصعبه
والواقحه
حتى كانت تتلقى نصيبها من الانتقادات في
الكتاب في حين اعفى هاري الملك تشارلز من
تعليقات مماثله وقبل اصدار الكتاب بايام
يقول هاري انه يرغب في عائله وليس مؤسسه
الملكيه بتلاعب في قصص العائله وتسريباتها
هو يريد روايه جانبه من القصه وتجريد
المؤسسه الملكيه من حصريه روايتها ولكنه
مع كشفه لتفاصيل حساسه في كتابه المتوقع
يبدو ان الامير هاري مشغولا ببناء مهنه
الاعلاميه خارج قيود المؤسسه الملكيه
مخاطرا ربما دعائته التي كما يقول يرغب
باستعادتها بشده من لندن لصباح العربيه
اسم كتاب الامير هاري الذي سيعرض هذا
الشهر وسبيرمانقول عن قول ماثور قديم في
الاوساط الملكيه مفاده ان الابن الاول
وريث الالقاب والسلطه والثروه والثاني
احتياطي حال حدوث اي شيء للبكر توجه الى
العلا الى نادين التي نستغني لميس الى
لميس بعدين
العلاقه
الاسبانيه من الكتاب
عليها عام 2019
وكدمات على ظهره وشرح هذه في مذكراته ايضا
انه عارضه وليا زواج والده من كامله التي
لا تتقينه الملك اليوم خوفا من ان تكون
زوجه
ولم يتوانها رعا الاعتراف بعدد من الاسرار
المتعلقه به شخصيا ومنها اقراه بتعاطي
الكوكايين وبانه قتل 25 مقاتلا معاذيا
خلال مشاركته في المهام العسكريه في
افغانستان على كل حال سال الناس بريطانيا
ما رايكم باصدار الامير هاري كتابا انتقد
فيه اسرته
سبايدر مان
[موسيقى]
معرفه
محمد شبارو اهلا بك استاذ محمد ومن العلا
تبقى معنا زميره العزيزه نادين محمد اهلا
بك نبدا معاك بالنقاش انا ونادين نادين
العلا وانا هون العربيه حاول الموضوع كتاب
هاري جديد يعني بريطانيا تحت الصدمه بسبب
انتقادات اهلا بك بسبب انتقادات والتهامات
الامير هاري في كتابه الجديد هل يمكن
القول اليوم انه لا مجال
للتعاطف مع الامير الشاب بسبب كتابه
مع الامير هاري وهو كان امير محبوبا من
مؤسسه الحكم من العائله الملكه البريطانيه
لكافه بين كافه اعضاء او افراد الشعب
البريطاني قد ما له من هذه التسريبات ومن
هذه الكتابات ومن هذه المقابلات ومساله
دربه الخصوصيه خصوصيه العائله الملكيه
الداخليه انت تعلمين يعني نحن افراد لطالم
كان هناك خلافات بين الاخوه تتسبب بها
الوظائف المنافسه ربما قضايا وامور اخرى
ولكن ان يخرج ذلك الى العلم بالشكل الذي
خرج به قد ربما ذهب يعني الى درجه ابعد
مما يتحمله الراي العام لبريطاني وايضا
هؤلاء يقولون كما سمعنا من المقابلات في
الشارع بانه همم يعني اخطا في الكشف عما
يكشف عنه اي همم اخوه خييين ممكن ان
يختلفا بسبب اراء مختلفه عن شركه حياه
الاخر بسبب موقف الوالد ولكن لا ان تكتب
ذلك في الصحافه خصوصا انك ابن ووريس
للعائله الملكيه البريطانيه
نادين استاذ شباره صباح الخير اولا من
العلا يسعد صباحكم
طيب استاذ محمد الاسره الحاكمه في
بريطانيا لطالما غرقت في فضائح ازمات
عائليه وتجاوزتها بعد مذكرات هاري هل
الصوره اكبر الازمه اكبر ام لا
تشهد العائله على مستوى من هذا الخلاف
العالمي ربما كان هناك
خلاف بهذا الوضوح ولم تخرج الى السطح نحن
اصبح امامنا
يا استاذ نادين مسلسل الاخوه الاعداء في
نسخته الانجليزيه الملكيه
الامير المتمرد همم يعني كلمه قليله لان
فصول هذا المسلسل ما زالت تتوالى همم نعم
هناك من يتابع هناك من بدا بطلب نسخ
الكتاب على امازون لانه اصبح متوفره ولكن
ايضا هناك مقابلات يدلي بها الامير هاري
ويواصل شرح بعض القضايا واتقاء الضوء على
قضايا اخرى
ويتساءل كثيرون خصوصا المعلقون الملكيون
هنا بان همم يعني هاري لم يترك جسرا يعود
اليه الى حضن العائله والده طبعا متاثر
للغايه يقال انه ينقل اصدقاء الامير وليام
وهذا خرج اليوم في صندل تايمز همم ينقل
عنه استشاطته غضبا من ما يخرج من فم اخيه
وح انه غير مصدق
و يتاسف اللي ما يجري وذلك كله منقول عن
اصدقاء للامير ويليام ولي العهد البريطاني
وبالتالي همم هو همم الامير هاري يطرح
رغبه في الجلوس واذا صح التعبير جلسه
عائليه وفضفضه ولكن يخشى هؤلاء في القصر
ايضا انه اليوم الثاني
سيشل نسخه كتاب هي
ربما اسافر العجله الاحتياط همم اللاعب
الاحتياطي رقم اثنين
متواليه
عند تاثر عند التاثف ام لا توقع تحركا من
القصر الملكي خصوصا انه بعد مسلسل او
وثائقي هناك فليكس عن الامير هاري لم او
يلتزم الصمت القصر الملكي هل تتوقع ان
يتحرك هذه المره ام لا
انا اعتقد انه في الكواليس ربما هناك
جهود تبذل
لوسطاء في العائله مهمين ولكن لا اعتقد ان
هناك اي كلام عاده القصر الملكي هي ان
يلتزم الصمت فيها في هكذا امور وربما تخرج
بعض وجهات النظر او الايحاءات عن طريق
اصدقاء عن طريق مقربين عن طريق ربما همم
يعني مراسلين ملكين اي هؤلاء المقربون من
القصر والمعلقون هناك ربما يذكرون هذه
المعلومه او تلك ولكن الصمت يلف قصر
باكينغهام ومؤسسات الحكم البريطانيه
طالما كشف المستور يعني بطريقه مخيفه
ومعلومات صادمه هل يمكن ان يسال الستار عن
القصه الغامضه لوالده هاري ليدي دي والتي
رحلت في حادثا مازال حتى اليوم يضع علامات
استفهام حوله
لم يصدق مساله انه حادث بسيط وبالتالي انا
اعتقد ان يعني سؤالك جدا مهم بانه سيتم
الحديث اكثر واكثر عن كيفيه وقوع هذا
الحادث خصوصا انه مذكرات هذه تقول ببساطه
انه ذهب وعبر هذا الجسر او هذا النفق اكثر
من مره وهو لم يفهم لماذا لم توجه اي
ادانات او اي اتهامات للمصورين الفقرات زي
همم في حينه وبالتالي همم اصول همم مشكله
هاري ووليليم ستواصل مشكله
مع
المؤسسات الحكم الملكيه في بريطانيا
ستواصل وايضا اا مساله ثغرات ما او او
تحقيقات ما سيطالب بها همم هاري ربما تعيد
فتح هذا الملف لانه من الواضح ان هاري
يتصرف كما يتصرف اليوم لانه
لم يتمكن من يعني ترك او اغلاق فصل وفاه
والدته المثير للجدل شكرا جزيلا لك سيد
محمد شبارك وحدثنا من لندن شكرا لك على
هذا النقاش الذي شاركت فيه زميله نادي
الخماش مباشره من العلاونه